thank you
[Music]
all right so
um there is this mother whoa April Fools
this is mother who uh recently uh posted
online got a a little bit of an
embarrassing moment that she had with
her son her son is six years old
um where he found her little baby
not a vibrator not battery powered just
a suction cup version of a large penile
thing okay the ones that you stick on
the wall
wow
and uh he found it and this is what he
decided to do with it uh oh please just
be a microphone
what is he doing karate
what are you doing well where did you
find that to oh
she was he was using it to do karate oh
he's like dude yeah
is that UK yeah of course
and he for real has no idea what it is
either this is [__] fake no why 100
fake why why you think this [__]
honestly wants everyone to see the giant
[__] deal that she's taken
or did she set this up to get to mind
those views bro hey I think uh it costed
for six-year-old son but the cost she
put this video up she pushed what do you
mean the cost and like she just caught
him right then and there come on but
maybe that that's her that's uh so you
you think she's getting the penis out
to get more views I think she's raking
views does she have a lot of other
videos like that or is that oh yeah cook
it in the kitchen making shepherd's pie
or whatever
you know a classic yeah what is she
doing I don't know making some
buttons
yeah it's a thing dude you're gonna make
a funny video what's the rest of her
profile look like I was born tonight
wasn't laughing you guys are really
making me pick up her [__] profile
well this is a real question this is
something this isn't like stop talking
this article can we just talk about the
fact that she wouldn't she be actually
embarrassed and not this [__]
[__] where she's filming it in it it
is funny but it's just from the UK she
has UK humor oh
okay that does change things they're not
sexually shame shameful like we are too
I think I think they're just okay I
didn't know that that's dry pushy humor
yeah yeah they got what I didn't say
anything
they
auction where a girl like we'll we'll
decide if she want a day to do it or not
and then the way that they'll have a
make a guide behind this like thing
right and then it'll just be like show
his legs first cool his [__] knee
first his [__] dick and then like
it's naked dick whoa like so she gets to
see like everything what is on Primetime
TV yeah and then the neck well it's like
after a certain time not prime time
three people spice Channel I'm gonna go
up to his neck and then and then so they
they go yeah I'll still date him and
then it goes and then you can see the
face and he's a naked guy just standing
so are there situations where they'll
see from the neck down they'd be like
yeah I'll still date this person and
they show the face and they're like nah
and then they're like oh like they lost
a game
you gotta marry him
that guy yeah I feel like the Japanese
will do it the other way they'll show
every other part of the body except for
the dick and the dick is last oh yeah it
goes like this it goes
retail price
and then they're like
I don't think they have the shame of
dick and all that stuff the way we do
don't you just feel like there's a lot
of other places in the world I think
it's opposite where you know here it's
like we're we're all we'll show all
those violence but then the sexual [__]
is a taboo but it's opposite the other
the other side of the world like Europe
or whatever they'll be like they'll hide
all the violence but they're okay with
all the sex [__] yeah titties and
commercials and stuff yeah way rather be
on the opposite side of the world stuff
then I ain't trying to see violence all
the time because they've seen [__]
titties and [__] in France yeah I'm down
to see titties all the time I'm not that
down to CJ's all the time me neither you
think you're gonna be that desensitized
yeah I just think that it will make me
too horny all the time I like I like
being horny from titties I don't so I
don't want it to be taboo no I wanted to
be taboo actually I want girls to keep
wearing something to cover it so it's
like a surprise yeah but if it's out all
the time it's not surprise it's National
Geographic yeah you don't want to get
desensitized right oh I'm a straight man
Anthony what about you
so your titties man or an ass man I'm a
straight man I like it I want to say
yeah I like them both no I mean I I an
ass man like I would say so because my
wife has a [__] ass but then I was
with I was with many chicks with titties
and no ass so I think I'm just a
straight guy
I've never been able to figure it out
can you identify
in fact my buddy was like I thought you
were a boob guy when I got Nikki and I
was like I don't know what's going on
there should be a quiz you should be
able to take online where it could
figure out
isn't it just one question what it
should be a whole website the whole
personality quiz yeah like a Harry
Potter house quiz but at the end of it I
think there's three yeah I think there's
three okay you're a boob guy a buck guy
or a feet guy and everyone judges defeat
yeah they do everybody judges the guy
who says that there's a fee guy there is
a feat guy though yeah that's for sure
they're the third ones they're also
there's also like a lot of Venn diagram
with like it's like feet guys and then
like Sims and like it's basically just a
complete circle
holy [__] dude I think I'm I think I'm a
Civic guy yeah they're paying like
chicks for foot shots and [__] like that
yeah
um what about the cuck Venn diagram does
that go in there too cooking what feed
guys feed guys there's all like directly
on top of each other three perfect
circles
the scientific definition of a cuck
again
someone who likes uh it's a brother
husband [__] yeah brother husband yeah
someone like someone seen their part see
their partner getting railed by somebody
else the f word you know what I'm
talking about yeah
very friendly guys are like can't
believe you're doing this to me but I'm
still gonna be here with you forever I'm
gonna make you dinner real quick so
you're hungry that was a really popular
genre before the incest stuff like oh I
can't pay my rent looks like my
girlfriend's got a [__] the landlord and
it always was some dingy like Russian
apartment yeah I like how the guy sits
there just to make sure that she's okay
yeah just for confirmation yeah and then
he's sitting there going oh I'm so sad
like you should be working right now
like we said that was super interesting
there's people with that jack off to it
they like that yeah like I but you know
what's weird don't get it do you think
more people are jacking off to that that
actually have Partners or ones that
don't and they're kind of simulating
that oh like they want to be the
landlord do you think they want to be
the landlord or do you think they want
to be the guy that's like no yeah that
like I think like I don't know if that's
people the relatability of is what makes
it a kink yeah well or like the idea
that you're just imagining that you even
have a partner to do that with and
there's like this like weird it's like
one level above just imagine you have a
partner you imagine you have a partner
that's cheating on you I don't know it's
almost VR right I'm just wondering if
it's mostly people with partners that
fantasize about that what if there's a
VR porn where you're the guy sitting on
the couch watching your [__] girl and
the landlord's like okay it's like and
then if you guys have played VR right
it's always like take the controllers
and place them in this location so you
like place them here
oh no I can't see
and all you see is pants if you start
walking over to your girl it puts the
boundary wall back up you can't go back
oh man you walk into your [__]
fireplace that's so lame step back in
your Zone
I know you see your hands
please place your controllers back up
this game is go get towels
like they said they would be down
uh because I did I think most most dudes
it's like yeah I'm down for a threesome
but I want another chicken most dudes is
like that yeah right yeah uh he said
he'd be down for another dude and I was
like what what the [__] that's crazy and
then he told me he's like actually it'd
be down
um to sit this one out this dude boning
my chick and I'm not even in it and I
said that turns you on and he was like
yeah
he wants to be in the closet jacking off
oh yeah I'm crazy I've heard of like
stories that's some cut [__] of like
white dudes wanting a black dude to bang
their wife
that's like a cup interesting it's a
very popular thing yeah I wonder why
so they could say oh no no
this is happening to me
[Laughter]
yeah and after after my friend said that
I just
you sometimes just run out of questions
yeah it's an awkward car ride home so if
you if you have to just for the sake of
this terrible conversation but you know
we've been super gay today already
anyway what are you talking about all of
us tuck stuff is not gay it's still
hetero exactly okay so it actually had
to what is somebody railing your chick
who would it be dude it's a it's a gun
in my hand bro yeah exactly
it's three bullets it's triple homicide
murder suicide I tell this every day
boom boom boom I would say Brett man
Rock oh
[Laughter]
kind of like
you do it that's what I'm saying he's
probably be nice yeah he probably
wouldn't want to do it but exactly he
probably couldn't get it up either
exactly I win that's not gonna work he
might be looking at Joe doing your lady
I win either way I win it's confusing
that's a weird situation [__] bubble
love sponge's wife what is that the one
that got caught in Cameron sold to yeah
Bubba the Love Sponge is like this radio
personality I don't know where but then
he he's friends with whole name huh yeah
and then he gets Hulk Hogan to rail his
wife and he's like filming the whole
thing yeah and like watching it and like
jerking to it like that and that's what
took down that whole website right yeah
and Hulk is his buddy
but then it's weird afterwards because
it's like hey dude thanks for real my
wife I came pretty hard at that
because you're friends yeah okay pretty
awesome at that level though it's the
equivalent of passing around a porn DVD
no I think it's your wife
literally
at that level there I feel like they're
[__] everyone and having orgies all
the time and they're bored that's what I
so the title doesn't matter they've had
so much sex that they need yeah maybe
you know if you're like at Rock Star
level and you got just nothing but
cocaine and orgies like in so many
different ways in so many different
places it's [__] at every angle yeah
yeah it's a thin line though between
like bored and dysfunctional though
that's like and Rockstar it's not hey
everyone [__] my wife it's I [__]
everything else too
the dynamic of like everyone come [__]
my wife I'm gonna just stay literally
everyone everyone come [__] my wife and
you know what I'll just jack off I'll
[__] myself yeah that's a good very
interesting Dynamic it is interesting
yeah it's interesting I'll make sure
everyone's well fed yeah I'll film it's
starting to sound fun
I'll just jack off it's fine I just love
to host parties that part is really good
at pitching this
certainly Cho talks about her open
relationships like and her boyfriend
would just pick up girls and they'll be
[__] in the other room and then
she'll make them breakfast in the
morning and stuff like that and I was
like that's interesting
dudes too yeah it's open see that's
different than that I guess it's
different [__] one the specific cook one
everyone come [__] my wife I jack off
the brother husband one too is like that
because then the guy's like why can't I
have a chicken she's like because you
can't and the guy's like okay okay
that's it it's just one try I want to
ask
[Music]
foreign